spicy Mexican eggs
this is a very classic Mexican style
brunch dish bold Kick-Ass flavors slice
the chili seeds in
garlic sliced nice and thinly
tablespoon of olive oil
I'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch you can see you
right through to dinner now to start the
sort of spicy fragrant tomato sauce get
your cumin in there
garlic chili roasted cumin red onions
already sounds Mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with your tomatoes
let them embarrassed using good canned
tomatoes I do all the time cooking at
home
Now by reducing that sort of come down
to a delicious paste leave that to
simmer
next canned beans called black beans
these are authentically Mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine just rinse them a little bit
of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb leaving the dense
beans to luxuriate in the spicy tomato
sauce will allow them to soften and soak
up all the flavor
next oil and season and oven proof dish
for my spicy egg brunch to baking
I'll just get some of that oil
around the outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half and then just stick them to the
side
these are a staple in Mexico
take one replace that in the center
get your mix
and place that on top of the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little flaps I want that crisp
shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just make a little hole in
there and then crack
the egg into the
again use a little point
put your egg in there one
two
three
four five and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside almost like it's a little dug out
and then one for the center
get a really nice rich delicious strong
Montgomery cheddar I want to grate the
tortilla shell as well so get generous
with it on the top and we'll season that
with these little babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon and they're going to spice
up that egg which is salt
such a pepper
sit that in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible
just a little bit of coriander to finish
it off
and that for me is what brunch is all
about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started spicy Mexican eggs in a
crispy tortilla shell
foreign we're hoping to wow the family
with an amazing quick fig Jam crostini
with creamy burrata and the hearty Mane
a big cheat Ragu with Papa Deli beef
cheeks just think the size of your
little cheeks yeah imagine the size of a
cow with them and the cheek is right
underneath here yeah
I always give them a really nice season
with salt and pepper on there please so
beef cheeks very cheap my cut that takes
sort of a long time to cook yeah but
give it a bit of love let it cook in the
oven it comes out like a dream a little
touch
of oil in the pan what we want to do is
get them really nicely colored shed see
it into the pan oh cool layaway
get what that is
um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the
beach beach
no matter what the onion chunky because
we're gonna cook it for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
and then again there and there so it
doesn't overcook
so a really good color on the cheeks
like that so how do you cook these at a
restaurant if they take so long they go
in the oven literally half past six
seven o'clock in the morning three and a
half four hours we're ready for lunch
and the longer you leave them in their
juices yeah and the cooking liquor the
better King eyes closed the garlic good
onions in and garlic in please nice
where's your Bailey there it is yes
get those onions and that garlic really
nicely colored
put the cheeks back in place right red
wine in cool okay the red wine is going
to deglaze the pan so deglaze will
basically sort of rinse all that flavor
off the bottom of the pan yeah okay
because that's going to make the most
amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree or
chopped canned tomatoes it'll make a
much better sauce I'm gonna top that
with some stock so the secret of
braising is having little of the meat
exposed and 90 of it submerged see them
now yeah
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out the water turn the gas
off and leave the lid just off at the
end there if we had to cover it
completely the steam hits the top yeah
the lid and all that water comes running
back solar still that's right in the
oven
140 150 for about three and a half to
four hours good job
Boom for pudding I'm making one of my
absolute favorite Italian desserts Banna
cotta with that quintessentially Italian
flavoring espresso
start by immersing two leaves of gelatin
in cold water and leave to soak
into a small saucepan add caster sugar
cream milk
sugar and a shot of good strong coffee
gently bring to a simmer and remove from
the hob
[Music]
ie's out the soaked gelatin leaves and
stir into the hot cream until completely
dissolved
pour your cream mixture into a jug and
fill your molds just short of the rim
rinsing your molds in cold water before
filling will make it easier to get your
panna cotta out once it's set
[Music]
leave in the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
[Music]
to make your cinnamon hazelnut brittle
pour caster sugar into a pan and cook
over medium Heat
until the sugar melts to a deep golden
brown
[Music]
scatter toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel
dust with ground cinnamon and leave to
set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm given each
mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
[Music]
dress with a Shard of crunchy hazelnut
brittle nothing could be so deliciously
elegant
right Captain Jack quick run through
Panna cottas are nearly set beef cheeks
I need it cooked we're gonna now do the
Fig and brighter crostini oh okay let's
take the figs we're gonna make a nice
slightly spicy fig Jam take off the tops
yep in half and each half into three
sugar a touch of salt in there okay
we're making a jam but we don't want a
bit too sweet and then these little
babies
what are they
ah what's the shape stars star
underneath taken from the fantasy plant
yeah and when you're drying like that so
intensifies the flavor really important
to count how many put in there okay yeah
so one two three four five so they're
just there from flavors and take them
out that's right secret here let's get
that camera going so when I hear a jam I
don't think of caramel
no but this is a very fast Jam caramel's
starting to color
I want you very carefully to drop the
figs in there good
so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the camera
you know what that is I'll sweep it in I
love that on my challenge you've got
that sort of sweet and sour flavor leave
that cooking for three four minutes
now let's slice out chapata in Italian
crostini means little bits of toast but
it could be made out of leftover
baguette sourdough or any crusty open
textured bread we're staying
authentically Italian with ciabatta
season them and then drizzle a little
touch of olive oil on there both sides
really important because we're going to
grill the bread push it down
it's a lovely very lovely take it off
with a chapata toasted we need to
carefully extract the star and these
pods from our piping hot fig Jam
my Jack we've got one little bugger to
find oh no
is it there yes it is right now we've
got the green light to crush
[Music]
skins disintegrated in that caramel that
looks so nice
oh Jack carefully spreads the crostini
with our hot fig Jam I can unveil the
last element to our starter the creamy
Italian specialty burrata
my little money bags
looking delicious this looks fun doesn't
it
we need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest imagine that sat there
and you tear some of that off and you
stick it on top of that and
back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks I've chosen to use
Papa Deli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salt and first good olive
oil in
pasta in
twist it round so you don't break it no
bring that back up the ball that's going
to take that through for four minutes
flat leaf parsley scrunch it up for me
yep and chop him now wait to see these
beef cheeks beauties
look at them
they're very soft tiny I want you to
taste
um
it's so good
yeah you just dribbled on your jumper
really
right drain the pasta
salt pepper
pasta
little drizzle
of olive oil
I'm going to put your fresh pasta nicely
chopped nicely chopped
in
this is the magic bit okay you take a
little Ladle of the juice
put that at the bottom
cook
the pasta
top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
gonna love you even more now you know
what about when you cook this for your
girlfriend one day uh just tell her
where you got the recipe from William
promise promise I don't want you
stealing Daddy's Thunder
one
beautiful jaw on there two beautiful
Jaws on there
and then the third job and then you go
over
with the source how cool is that
delicious you've got the burrata
and I've got the cheeks
let's go please
don't be cheeky get it
my ultimate Italian dinner
quick fig Jam crostini with creamy
borata a main course of slow cooked beef
cheek Ragu with Papa Deli and for
pudding espresso panna cotta with
cinnamon hazelnut brittle
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best Italian
tradition